okay I'm going to talk to you today
about diffusion osmosis and active
transport now all three of these are
examples of transport which is just how
particles move from one place to another
so I'm going to start off with diffusion
now nicely simply put diffusion is the
movement of particles from an area of
high concentration to an area of low
concentration so let's say I had a can
of deodorant and I sprayed it I'd have
lots and lots of deodorant particles
right here so at the moment I've
described this area here near the
deodorant can as being a high
concentration which means there's a lots
of these particles within this
particular volume now over time these
particles are going to move from an area
of high concentration to an area of low
concentration now they don't all
deliberately just move to the area of
low concentration they're all moving in
random directions over time we'll see
these becoming more spread out and
moving to a low concentration
now diffusion can happen in liquids and
gases because the particles are free to
move in solids because the particles are
held in place diffusion cannot occur so
only in liquids and gases now next up we
have osmosis osmosis has got a very very
particular definition that would be good
to learn it's the movement of water
molecules from an area of high water
concentration to an area of low water
concentration across a partially
permeable membrane so what we're going
to do is we're just going to break that
down and so we understand what that
means okay so I'm just finishing this
osmosis diagram here now what we have
here is we have two sides of a membrane
now a membrane this membrane allows
certain things to pass through it
and not other things these little blue
circles represent water molecules now we
can see that these water molecules
they're small enough to fit through this
membrane here however what we have on
this side these these black shapes
represents the sugar so in this case it
could be sucrose for example now this
sequence could be dissolved within this
solution so this is like a sugary
solution now because the sucrose is
dissolving in the solution we can see we
actually got a higher concentration of
water molecules on this side than this
side
as a result what's going to happen is
there's going to be a net movement that
means an overall movement of water
molecules from this area of high
concentration of water molecules to this
area of low concentration so Posh this
is a partially permeable membrane
partially means only something's
permeable means to go through so it
means only some things can go through in
this case water remember the higher the
concentration of sucrose this could also
be glucose it could be any sugar the
higher the concentration of this sugar
the lower the concentration of the water
on this side so it's the movement of
these water molecules from a high
concentration to a low concentration
through this partially permeable
membrane okay
next up we have active transport now
active transport kind of goes against
the grain so let's imagine that we've
got a membrane right here now let's say
this could be happening in a plant root
okay so let's say we've got certain
nitrates already in our plan right okay
so this is inside the plan root
this is the membrane separating the
inside and outside so let's say here is
the soil and here is inside our plant
now the problem is this time we want to
go from a low concentration of nitrates
let's say to a high concentration so
this is the only one which is instead of
going from a high to a low goes from a
low concentration to a high
concentration now as a result this
requires energy as a result this is why
it is called active transport active
transport because it requires energy to
move these move this nitrate from a low
concentration to a high concentration so
it's said to be against a concentration
gradient now all that means is it's
going from a low to a high now the only
other thing we need to know about is in
the membrane in this membrane here there
is a particular protein now this is the
bit that requires energy supply to the
protein to move this nitrate across from
the outside in to the inside from a low
concentration look there's only one of
it there's not many a really low
concentration here in so here where
there's a higher concentration so let's
have a quick recap and see where they
apply in plants so diffusion is the
movement of gases or liquids from an
area of high concentration to an area of
low concentration an example of
diffusion in a plant could be carbon
dioxide diffusing diffusing into a leaf
or oxygen diffusing out of a leaf so
it's the movement of gases or liquids
from a high concentration to a low
concentration remember as most it's the
movement of water molecules across a
partially permeable membrane
from an hour of high concentration to an
area of low concentration again both
these processes are said to be passive
because they do not require any energy
whereabouts might we find this in a
plant well the answer is in the plants
roots so within the roots of the plants
this is where we have the water entering
so that is where we have the process of
as most is happening in plant roots
now finally whereabouts would we have
this active transport taking place well
also in plant roots but only is to
transport nitrates and minerals rather
than water so that is transport of
diffusion osmosis and active transport
thank you